continue to have elevated signature CT DNA tests. I was taking 18 milligrams of Ivermectin
date, but ran out of sort of month ago at the CT DNA. While Ivermectin was going down,
the last result said running out of Ivermectin, it went up. Oh, well, that's interesting.
I was interested in high dose Ivermectin. Do you at present recommend these types of protocols?
Yes, absolutely. That's a sign that the 18 milligrams of Ivermectin is not at cancer dose yet,
really. More like 60 would be cancer dose, so 18 milligrams I think would be still too low,
but if 18 milligrams was low or a CT DNA test, then it would be really interesting getting
it up to something like 60 to see what that would do. What do you suggest as far as where to go
to purchase Ivermectin? Is there anywhere in the US where you don't need a prescription?
No, I think you do need a prescription. There's places in the US that you can buy Ivermectin
and they'll have a doctor call you and do a full thing with you to get Ivermectin. You can also
call the clinic and give you a date with a doctor that you might be able to contact to get Ivermectin.
We just talked to somebody else that is a PA that might be able to give scripts for Ivermectin
too, so give the clinic a call. Yeah, Dr. William Marcus has a bunch of stuff on Ivermectin
for the kids here. Yes, I saw his videos and stuff. Those are good.